buonasera a tutti io avevo voglia di
cominciare con una con una frase che può
toccare dicendo ma questa cosa ci viene
a rompere dicendo il futuro non esiste
virgola concretamente ma esiste qui è la
cosa più interessante è e questo è il
mio lavoro io sono architetto urbanista
ma sono anche antropologa e cercare di
capire come il futuro si pensa non
quello che succederà questi sono quelli
che si chiamano futurologi io non mi
occupo di quello che succederà a me
quello che interessa è capire come oggi
noi pensiamo al nostro futuro il futuro
è qualcosa di è una costruzione il
futuro non esiste concretamente cioè nel
senso che il passato lo possiamo toccare
il passato
tocchiamo i muri vediamo i monumenti
patrimonio
queste sono quelle che noi chiamiamo
rappresentazioni del passato e sono li
rivediamo questo palco questo edificio
beh noi stessi anche ma in futuro
no cioè non possiamo toccare niente
neanche le nuove applicazioni sono il
futuro perché sono state pensate cinque
anni fa quindi abbiamo uno strano
rapporto il futuro è qualcosa che
fondamentalmente una nostra capacità di
proiettarci allora qualcuno lo fa per
professione altri rifanno sognando
semplicemente e questo futuro e quello
che in questo momento sta ritornando ad
essere il centro un po dei discorsi
degli ultimi 23 anni nel senso che nel
discorso delle città fino a poco tempo
fa eravamo dentro a una bolla
che si chiama presentismo
nel senso che pensavamo solo al presente
fermati lì e questo perché perché
pensare al futuro è una cosa di me è una
cosa diversa difficile estremamente
complicata
in un momento in cui le tecnologie per
esempio hanno prodotto un'accelerazione
incredibile nel senso che adesso la
maggior parte penso di voi ha in tasca
un oggetto che fino a poco tempo fa non
pensava di avere potete guardare le
email mentre io parlo perché magari sono
poco interessante allora guardo l'email
sfoglio guardo twitter
guardo cosa fanno i miei amici su
facebook eccetera eccetera
questa cosa
fino a 15 anni fa avere un
fondamentalmente un computer in tasca
che era nei film ci vedevamo nei film
queste cose qui dove c'erano questi
oggetti sempre un po strani
oppure pensate a skype io la prima volta
che ho visto skype è stato in guerre
stellari dove c'era yoda che appariva
davanti a me e non da vinci a me
sfortunatamente spariva così e yoox che
luke skywalker ci parlava insieme io
adesso lo faccio da parigi con mia mamma
che non hai o da ma vorrebbe esserlo ma
la cosa che è interessante è vedere che
alcune cose che noi abbiamo visto nei
film di fantascienza sono diventate un
po il nostro quotidiano e questo è da
una parte molto divertente anche se non
ce ne rendiamo veramente conto ma
dall'altra parte hanno questa
accelerazione questo fatto di poter fare
le cose che luke skywalker faceva hanno
ridotto rimpicciolito la mia capacità di
proiettarsi nel futuro perché
fondamentalmente è come faccio io sapere
quello che succede l'anno prossimo se le
tecnologie sono così veloci che dieci
anni fa io avevo un telefonino che così
che faceva che telefonare e adesso ma in
meno di tre anni o dei telefoni che
fanno tutto
questa cosa è un po difficile e e c'è
questo piccolo paradosso per cui un
accelerazione tecnologica porta un
rimpicciolimento dalla nostra capacità
di proiettarci nel futuro non so se
molti di voi ci hanno pensato questa
cosa però culturalmente noi siamo dentro
a un sistema che ereditiamo cioè nel
senso che ereditiamo veramente come il
colore degli occhi cioè non ci possiamo
fare niente
noi siamo dentro un sistema di pensiero
qui in occidente per cui il futuro è
sicuramente migliore sicuri nel senso
che la tecnologia sarà sempre migliore
noi saremo sempre migliori moriremo
molto in maniera sempre più vecchi
diciamo e tutto questo abbiamo in testa
siamo dentro questo questo pensiero che
è iniziato a un certo momento non è non
ci abbiamo avuto sempre un certo momento
c'è stata una rivoluzione intorno al
1600 in cui queste cose si sono
cominciate a pensare così e quindi è un
po difficile scardinare qualcosa che è
stato pensato così problema è ok
rendiamocene conto e tutto va bene il
fatto è capire che siamo dentro a una
costruzione cioè nel senso che noi
pensiamo al futuro
mettendoci dentro tutta una serie di
cose e una di queste cose è la credenza
quasi religiosa che il nostro futuro
sarà migliore questo vi assicuro è
almeno
secoli clos pensiamo che il nostro
futuro sarà salvato dalla tecnologia
la tecnologia la tecnica che non sono la
stessa cosa hanno in mano
diciamo le sorti del nostro futuro ha
chiaramente siamo noi che ne produciamo
però diamo a loro un po la il potere di
fare in modo che il nostro futuro sia
migliore e quindi le scoperte della
scienza è quello e quell'altro che tutto
è un po legato questa cosa e va
benissimo sono stato che siamo dentro
questa cosa però ogni tanto io penso se
dico certo reso un telefono è un
telefonino che pensa benissimo è
intelligente sa che smartphone teli
gente e mi dice dove sono sempre lui lo
sa dove sono io a cerci certe volte non
lo so dove sono pro lui lo sa quando io
mi perdo lui lo sa dove sono io e e
pensa e mi dice che sono i miei amici
eccetera eccetera
ogni tanto penso ma guarda dieci anni fa
e non ci aveva un telefonino così i
dieci anni fa però mi sapevo orientare
molto di più forse cioè almeno mi
sprecava un po di più orientarmi in
città
avevo i numeri di telefono dei miei
amici a memoria cioè usavo un po di più
la mia testa e adesso la uso un po di
meno perché no il telefonino un
pezzettino delle cose che dovrei fare io
un po come la mia segretaria personale
in tasca e questo questo dare alla
tecnologia e consegnare alla tecnologia
quello che noi dovremo continuare a fare
come esercizio e qualcosa anche questo
che fa parte di un sistema
dentro questo sistema
una cosa che è interessante è il fatto
che il futuro
quando pensiamo al futuro la città è
sempre qualcosa che apriamo subito come
soggetto principale cioè raramente
vediamo dei film di fantascienza girati
in campagna in montagna al mare c'è un
evidente fin in campagna
raramente sono tutti ulterior barney c'è
nel senso che abbiamo una
rappresentazione di quello che sarà la
città futura di quello che è il mondo
futuro scusate estremamente urbano cioè
siamo davanti a un iper urbanità un
urbanità che però ha delle carit
caratteristiche che sono sempre un po le
stesse una città di grattacieli o una
città sotterranea pensate veramente film
di fantascienza anche se non siete
appassionati però ci sono dei film
guerre stellari a blade runner che
rappresentano la città veramente in
maniera stereotipata cioè nel senso che
è una città quasi sempre illuminata di
notte con questi grattacieli infiniti
dove le strade non si vedono spesso
perché abbiamo degli auto volanti e
quindi questa è un'immagine che è come
una ricetta che noi facciamo sempre per
rappresentarci il futuro perché vi
racconto queste cose perché nel 2007 a
parigi si è cominciato a parlare della
grande parigi in forse qualcuno di voi
ne ha sentito parlare
un grande progetto per pensare di nuovo
il futuro della capitale durante quel
periodo stato fatto un grande concorso
di architettura qualche architetto che
aveva presentato e aveva e concorreva a
questo concorso mi aveva chiamato per
sapere se volevo fare parte della sua
equipe e a un certo punto erano molto
contenta all'inizio che mi chiamassero
io dirigo un laboratorio di ricerca
all'università di architettura che si
chiama architettura antropologia è un
certo punto mi sono detta
no non voglio fare parte di questo
grande concorso
ma non perché questi architetti che mi
avessero chiamato non erano simpatici
gentili e e quant'altro ma perché quello
che mi interessava sempre più e ne
vedere il processo che si stava mettendo
in corso nel senso che mi rendevo conto
che ero davanti a una possibilità di
vedere qualcosa che si stava formando ma
se stavo dentro a una di questa equipe
non avrei potuto vedere forse in maniera
molto più generale quello che stava
succedendo e quindi ho fondato qualcosa
che si chiama osservatorio della grande
parigi che dal 2000 e diciamo 8 fino
adesso lavora su questi processi
cioè lavora su come la città si pensa
nel futuro e la cosa interessante che lo
abbiamo cominciato a fare è prima di
tutto ha detto beh siamo dentro questa
cosa della grande parigi
guardiamo quello che gli architetti
producono abbiamo lavorato due anni con
gli architetti abbiamo cercato di capire
abbiamo guardato tutto quello che
producevano eccetera eccetera è però
eravamo veramente strabiliati della
della poca fantasia nel senso che
ritrovavamo quelle ricette della città
del futuro quindi grattacieli illuminati
certe volte c'era qualcosa che volava
perché bisogna sempre fare qualcosa che
vola certo molto ecologici adesso però
le macchine magari non vanno più a
benzina vanno anche a pannelli solari
però sono sempre le macchine e
e non vedevamo niente di particolare e
qui vi abbiamo detto ok
cerchiamo di capire che cosa vuol dire
questa cosa e quindi abbiamo cominciato
visto che siamo in una città che ha un
sacco di esperienza su questa cosa a
vedere che parigi è da dal 1771 che si
immagina nel futuro abbiamo scoperto che
questa città ha una tradizione di futuro
strana cosa nostra tradizione di futuro
nel senso che nel 1771 parigi fa scritta
e produce una prima ucronia cioè nel
senso una prima trasposizione temporale
verso un tempo molto lontano prevedere
come a questa società storia banale
classicissima qualcuno si addormenta e
si risveglia 1700 anni dopo e cioè
questo libro che si chiama parigi
nell'anno 2440 scritto nel 1761 qualche
anno prima
la rivoluzione francese e così da lì
abbiamo trovato 56 per il momento
romanzi che trasportano parigi e nel
8.545 nel 3.222 eccetera eccetera
una produzione incredibile di futuri
fino agli anni 50 60 e poi sempre meno
adesso sempre meno adesso non ce ne sono
non c'è più un romanzo su parigi nel
3200 c'è qualcosa che si chiama parigi
2030 al 2033 15 anni cioè io 60 anni fra
15 anni non è che sono vecchia e quindi
abbiamo detto che strano cioè nel senso
come è possibile che che non si produca
non sia più siamo più capaci a produrre
queste
e quindi abbiamo detto no al nostro
osservatore deve fare un'altra cosa
ancora non sono gli architetti non solo
la storia del futuro ma dobbiamo andare
a cominciare a guardare quello che la
gente gli abitanti di parigi pensano nel
futuro c'è un senso che vogliamo capire
qual è il significato e che cosa
mettiamo dentro questa ricetta
quando pensiamo al futuro della città e
quindi abbiamo cominciato il con il
comune di parigi a fare tutta una serie
di ricerche su che cosa vuol dire
abitare per esempio in altezza nei
grattacieli oppure che cosa vuol dire
essere in mezzo delle trasformazioni
urbane pazzesche e dentro queste
ricerche
quello che noi stiamo cercando di fare è
capire come le persone possono
sviluppare o possono riapprendere a fare
quello che facevamo da ragazzini cioè
proiettarsi ma tanto lontano al di là di
noi perché proiettarsi nel futuro non
vuol dire proiettarsi per la mia
generazione vuol dire avere una
coscienza su quello che altre
generazione potranno avere e questa cosa
non è nel 2020 nel 2030 nel 2040 e
cominciare a pensare a parigi nel 3.015
e quando facciamo questi giochi queste
queste cose con gli abitanti di alcuni
quartieri
all'inizio c'è il gelo impossibile
parlare di questa cosa
e poi bisogna lasciare il tempo passare
e questo diventa un esercizio della
mente molto interessante e molto
interessante per gli architetti e molto
interessante per le persone che fanno la
città per capire dove l'immaginario
collettivo ci sta portando
e quindi per chiudere a me piacerebbe
molto che queste persone tutti voi
pensate a verona nel 3.015 grazie